to conservative groups are filing a
lawsuit against the University of
california-berkeley this comes after the
school canceled a visit by conservative
author and Coulter officials said it was
for security reasons and they offered to
reschedule violent protests broke out on
campus in February when another
conservative Milo Antonopoulos was
scheduled to speak John Blackstone is in
Berkeley California John good morning
good morning well it was of course here
on the Berkeley campus that the Free
Speech Movement was born in the 1960s
now Ann Coulter is battling to be heard
here after the university rescheduled a
speech planned for this week
now Coulter is insisting she's going to
come here as originally planned oh yes
I'm gonna be there Thursday on the
Berkeley campus College Republicans are
fighting to give Coulter a platform this
week they filed a lawsuit Monday trying
to force the university to ease
restrictions they say are only placed on
conservative speakers in a statement the
University says the allegation that miss
Coulter is being prohibited from
speaking because of her conservative
views is untrue instead they blame
outside agitators known as the black
bloc who rampaged across the campus in
February stopping a speech by the
controversial conservative Milo u
nopales and causing a hundred thousand
dollars in damage the university did
offer you another location at another
time what was wrong with that
unfortunately I wasn't available that
day moreover I found out later there are
no classes that week criticism isn't
only coming from the right but also from
staunch liberals like comedian Bill
Maher Berkley you know used to be the
cradle of free speech and now it's just
the cradle for babies and the fact that
people like Bill Maher and Bernie
Sanders are all coming out saying
Berkeley is out of its mind all of these
things come together to show how
cocooned and out-of-touch American
universities are today since the
election demonstrations against
conservative speakers have turned
violent on several campuses including
the University of Washington where one
man was shot in a clash between
protesters and coulter says the threats
won't stop her you can't wear a mask and
carry weapons can aspiring to to violate
someone's constitutional rights and
that's what this these groups up at
Berkeley are doing but those anarchist
groups may not be the only ones who show
up here the university has now received
threats from other groups saying they're
going to come here to support and
Coulter's right to speak that could lead
to some violent clashes here Alex John
thanks